RICH: OK, and we're live.
Hey there.
Welcome everyone, this is
"Android Development Office
Hours" live from Devoxx
here in Antwerp.
NICK BUTCHER: In Antwerp,
yeah, so hopefully
you can hear us.
We're in a noisy conference.
We've managed to find a little
place with some white lines
and beautiful logos behind us.
RICH: Yeah, just a few hours
after the recent Android
launches, the Nexus 10 and Nexus
4 have started shipping.
And we've got the new SDK out,
so we'll be talking about some
of the APIs and the new Android
developer tools as well.
NICK BUTCHER: Yep.
So we've got a whole bunch of
material to get through.
As always, we'll be taking
material from the Moderator,
which you'll be able to find at
developers.google.com/live.
And if you comment on the
Hangout thread as well, on the
Google+ Android developers page,
we'll be able to see
your comments on that.
And we can invite you into the
Hangout, and you can come
along and ask some questions
live at Devoxx.
RICH: Or if you're at Devoxx,
NICK BUTCHER: If you're
at Devoxx, somehow,
RICH: --then come ask us.
We're at the back of the
downstairs hall.
NICK BUTCHER: So excellent.
RICH: So many ways
to get in touch.
NICK BUTCHER: And thank you very
much, Chris, again, for
joining us in the
office hours.
Hopefully, you can make up some
of our deficiencies in
our limited setup here today
because we can't actually
reach the keyboard, it's
under there somewhere.
CHRIS: No boys.
RICH: We'll be able to see some
of the chat questions and
hopefully get back to
your questions.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm just trying
to load the Moderator on
roaming data.
RICH: Excellent, so the first
technical hitch being, we
can't see the Moderator, but
we promise to answer your
questions on it.
[LAUGH]
I'm just going to have a
look at the Moderator.
[LAUGH]
NICK BUTCHER: Why don't we just
go to some of the point
4.2, first.
So I think very exciting, 4.2
has got some nice new
interesting APIs which all
you developers have--
and here the SDK 9 downloading
the latest and greatest and
going over the API [? dif, ?]
seeing what's new
and important.
So I think for me, I think one
of the main things I want to
make sure people are aware
about are the changes to
content providers, right?
So now, by default if you're
testing your app on SDK 17,
and you change your target SDK,
that's got an implication
for that default value
for content
providers exported setting--
so it's like whether or not
you're exposing your content
provider to other
applications.
It used to be default
to public.
It's now changed, if you change
your target SDK to
default not to public.
So you might-- if you're relying
on that default value,
somehow, and not setting it
explicitly, then you may have
changed behavior.
So just be really aware of what
that means to the house.
RICH: Yeah, as soon as you start
targeting API level 17,
[INAUDIBLE]
publicly enable your
content provider.
For me, the new API is for
dreams, Daydreams, and locked
screen widgets, that I'm
most excited about.
We'll be giving away some swag
here to any developers at
Devoxx that come to our stand
with a brand new locked screen
widget or Daydream.
The Daydreams, as you may
already know, is like a screen
saver API very similar
to wallpapers.
You implement them yourself,
and you can expose, in an
interactive manner, your content
onto the display of
the device as it goes
to sleep, or once
its charging or docked.
NICK BUTCHER: And for me, it's
the presentation API.
I think it's one of the most
exciting APIs in 4.2.
So it lets you create different
content for
different screens.
So there's been a lot of buzz
about the Miracast, which is
coming in the Nexus 4, this
device, to allow wireless
sharing to displays.
But the same API works over HDMI
as well, so you can start
writing applications right now
that use the presentation API,
and any 4.2 device [INAUDIBLE]
to use it over HDMI as well.
I think it's a really nicely
thought out API.
So you get a different context,
which will reload
different assets depending on
the resolution and the density
of the target display which
you're sending it too, which
is really nice.
There's some really nice
changes with the
media router bars.
So the media router allows you
to send content to the best
screen available, essentially,
and also the media router
provider, which will allow you
to route video and audio to
the best sync for it.
So there's some standard
components you can put into
your app now to take advantage
of these things.
So really exciting stuff.
I can't wait to see what
people build with that.
RICH: Absolutely.
On the stand here at Devoxx
we're demoing the Nexus 10 on
our 50 inch plasma screen.
Of course, the Nexus 10, with
its 2,500 by 1600 pixel
display, has to downscale for
our 50 inch, full HD plasma.
NICK BUTCHER: You're like,
oh, it doesn't look so
good on the 50 inch.
I like it better on the 10.5.
RICH: Every time I say, 2,500,
Roman tells me off because
it's 2,560, and those extra
60 pixels are important.
Along with the extra 48
pixels on the Nexus 4.
48?
720 to 760--
48 more pixels.
Your UIs, of course,
will sync to scale.
The display resolution on the
Nexus 10, as Nick will
demonstrate for us, is still a
10 inch tablet, and this is
the first XHDPI 10
inch tablet.
Pretty much every single
previous Android tablet has
been NDPI, so a resolution
density of one.
And because this is XHDPI,
it's got a density of 2.
So all your layouts that were
done in dips are just going to
scale perfectly.
It's 1240 by 800 dips,
the same as
previous 10 inch tablets.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, one thing
to watch out for is, well,
we've been testing a bunch of
apps on this device before
launch, and pretty much
everything scaled beautifully.
One or two apps out there might
have used pixel sizing
rather than dip sizing
[INAUDIBLE].
And they find most of your
content would reflow nicely,
and then one element would be
like too short, for example.
Because it wasn't getting
scaled up.
So one thing to watch out for.
Oh, we've been joined
by Matt as well.
MATT: Hey
RICH: Yes, it's the pure layout
that you saw before,
but are we getting the assets
from the XHDPI folder from
your phone's layouts, if you had
phone layouts inside the
Galaxy Nexus.
So hopefully everything
will look perfect.
Who else has joined
us down there?
I'm just ducking heads.
Joe.
[INAUDIBLE]
If people in the Hangout want
to ask questions, they're
going to have to wave a bit, and
I'm going to go near into
the laptop where I can.
--Which I'll do right now.
NICK BUTCHER: We could just
like zoom in a bit.
We could just like
move forward.
AUDIENCE: What are the
things that you said
about the new DPIs?
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: The new DPIs, you're
moving to the [? gradle ?]
system.
It's so weird that we can have
and builds that have
[? worked ?]
poorly [INAUDIBLE]
XXHDPI in, so people who don't
have XXHDPI don't get them
assets as well.
RICH: Interesting.
The question is [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: Can't hear, Rich.
NICK BUTCHER: Rich, speak up.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
I'm talking to the laptop,
not the microphone.
I was trying to repeat
the question.
I think the question was, can
we make APKs that don't have
the XXHDPIs assets in to
go to some devices.
Yeah?
Someone nod if that
was the question.
No.
Not at the moment.
Multiple APK doesn't.
NICK BUTCHER: What
was the question?
I missed it.
Can you make APKs which--
so that you can do XXHPDI assets
and make a very big APK
to devices that support it, but
then for other devices--
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH: OK, Devoxx brain
fuzz right now.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
APK, you can split on--
NICK BUTCHER: Support screen.
RICH: You can split
on support screen.
You can do it for x-large,
but not for XHDPI.
NICK BUTCHER: I think you can.
RICH: You can definitely do it
on screen size, so maybe you'd
want to do the smaller screen
sizes and the bigger screen
sizes in different, but
I don't think you
could do it on density.
Matt, Chris, someone
who's got access to
Dart compatible screens?
AUDIENCE: I would've thought
there would have been a way of
saying, if it supports
screens,
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: And I'll just
sit here, smiling.
Can you still hear us?
Somebody speak?
MATT: Yeah, we can.
Hello?
RICH: Damn it, I
can't hear you.
Are you speaking?
MATT: Yeah, we are.
We're talking.
CHRIS: Well, Matt's talking.
RICH: Oh, there you are.
OK, this is a little bit of
fail, but if we just rewind
for the last couple of minutes
I'll be able to hear what
people in the Hangout
are saying.
So I thnk the answer was no.
But hopefully [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: I have
Moderator now.
RICH: And we have Moderator
now as well.
Let's jump into the
first person from
the Moderator, then.
Also, I should turn the camera
around, so you can see what's
going on here.
But we're in the middle
of a hall with about
2000 people in it.
So if we see somebody we know,
we'll drag them in.
Hopefully, we can get some of
these Android framework
engineers to come and sit on
one of our knees here.
We've only got two chairs.
I'll take Roman, he's
slightly lighter.
Moderator, then.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, let's
get a question.
"How does the Google Play
search index work?
I have an app that is called--"
something I can't
pronounce in Spanish--
"but Hispanic search index
doesn't rank it." OK.
To which Sparky-- has
Sparky joined us?
Sparky's not with us
at the moment.
NICK BUTCHER: He pinged us
trying to join but he hasn't
done it yet?
RICH: Oh, did he ping
us trying to join?
NICK BUTCHER: Yep.
He's given a pretty
good answer.
RICH: Go on, can you read that
amazing LG Nexus 4 screen?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH: Whilst Nick decodes
Sparky's answer--
NICK BUTCHER: I'm trying
to read it.
RICH: Ah.
NICK BUTCHER: How does the
Google Play search engine work
is basically the question.
RICH: Yeah, generally we can't
answer that, but--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, but Sparky's
given some very good
advice, so check the
Moderator out.
Basically, it's saying don't use
very generic words because
they're going to be highly
competed against.
Generally, it comes down to
normal stuff, like we're going
to rank apps based on a lot of
signals, much like Google
Search, which we don't
give the exact
algorithm out to, obviously.
But it's the stuff
you'd expect.
It's going to be things like
that the quality of your app,
the ratings, how good your
listing, the number installs,
the number of people who install
the app and then
uninstall it, and lots
of signals like this.
So generally, the advice is
always just write a really
good app, and concentrate on the
app quality, and represent
it very fairly in
the description.
If you don't try and use a
keyword section, where you
list every single keyword
you can think of in the
description because that's
actually something we think is
the sign of a bad quality app,
someone who's trying to game
the system.
So you'd be penalized for
that kind of behavior.
So just don't try and be too
clever, concentrate on
quality, and write a
fair description.
And that'll work.
The only exceptions to that rule
is if you have a name of
an app which is kind of close
to a dictionary word but a
slight play on it, then
sometimes our search does
something called query
rewriting, where it says, we
think did you mean kind of
queries, where it thinks
you've done a typo and it's
trying to be really helpful in
correcting it--
if there is a case of that,
where you are close to a
dictionary word, and people
are getting their query
rewritten to the dictionary word
rather than your app's
name, then that, obviously,
we need to know about.
So you can use the Report
Problem on the Google Play
developer support to actually
report that to us, and we'll
try and factor that
into the ranking.
Yeah, there's a great contact
form on Google Play developer
support where you can
report things back
to the support team.
Search appears to
be one of them.
And hey, Sparky.
Thanks for joining us.
SPARKY RHODE: Hey.
Hey, were you guys talking about
the applications that--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPARKY RHODE: --doesn't
show up in the store?
NICK BUTCHER: Nope.
RICH: [LAUGH]
Yes we were, Sparky.
SPARKY RHODE: OK, so what
happened was, actually, that
app's search result is
correctly placed.
But the primary title of
the app is in English.
So when you search for it
in Spanish, if your user
interface is in English,
you're not
going to see it all.
RICH: Fair enough.
I hope the developer gets
that message then.
SPARKY RHODE: I actually
reported that as a feature
request to the Store, that if
you get an exact title match
in the language that's not
the primary locale,
show the exact match.
NICK BUTCHER: What's going on?
RICH: I know, sorry dude, this
guy can't hear a word
that's going on.
But what we do have is Paul
Kinlan pulling faces at us
over there.
CHRIS: [LAUGH]
NICK BUTCHER: Should I go
back to the Moderator?
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
oh just see if-- there's someone
without a picture,
maybe they have a question.
Also we have something in
the comments down there.
OK, no, it's just Matt
adding Sparky.
Yeah, Sparky, do you want
to grab the next
note from the Moderator?
SPARKY RHODE: I'm [INAUDIBLE].
RICH: Sparky, Nick would like
to read it so he knows what
the hell is going on.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, good question
from Andrew, the
self-named one-man Moderator
machine Kelly says, "Regarding
regarding user switching in
Android 4.2, how does that
affect Google Cloud messaging?
Progressive I register a device
ID as one user on my
server, will other users have
different device IDs.
If it's a single ID, how is a
notification presented to user
A if user B is using the
device?" [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Oh,
you need this.
[LAUGH]
You're not even listening.
We're single-threaded today.
It's either Rich or Me.
RICH: Yeah, we're slightly
distracted.
I was going to show you what
the conference looks like.
See that?
[INAUDIBLE]
Well, there it is.
And still, I didn't answer
the question [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So, do you know
the answer, so if you have
multiple users on a device,
do they get different
registration IDs [INAUDIBLE].
Or is the same registration
ID?
CHRIS: Tied to your Google
account, isn't it?
RICH: It's totally going to
be different ones, yeah.
It's tied to your
Google account.
So the Google account
that they logged in
with, it's tied to.
So it's a a device
and account pair.
RICH: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: I think that's
right as well.
RICH: So potentially, if you're
logged in with the same
account under different business
on the same device,
you should have multiple
registrations.
NICK BUTCHER: So what happens
if the user isn't
foreground and then--
So I think it's the exact same
behaviors as if the device was
off, right?
So yeah, that's right.
If I switch to another account,
then all the sudden
all my notifications
come through.
RICH: Sounds good to me.
SPARKY RHODE: I thought I'd
heard some messaging that
implied that, for example, you
would continue to get your
Gmail in the background even
when you weren't logged in.
But I don't have a
source on that.
It was just something I heard.
RICH: OK, I'll check it out.
Gmail in the background
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Next.
AUDIENCE: I think that whoever
writes documentation
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Can't you tell
the person who writes
documentation for GCM to
put that in there?
RICH: Sorry, we really
can't hear you.
Hopefully Sparky can.
SPARKY RHODE: Are you looking
at the action bar question?
AUDIENCE: No, about the GCM.
If the person who writes that
can put some information about
multi-users, how that works?
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
I can't hear it.
Oh, the joys of doing things
live from a conference.
At least we have new devices.
We did "Android Design in
Action" live from the
conference yesterday.
That was really nice.
RICH: Well, you were smart and
chose a room, as opposed to
the conference floor, which
is a little bit noisier.
But conference floor,
you'll get signage.
Signage is very important
for--
SPARKY RHODE: The signage
is beautiful.
I envy you.
NICK BUTCHER: Shall I
do another question?
RICH: We just went to an awesome
talk, a talk by Chet
Haas, lunchtime talk today.
It's just a short,
30 minute talk on
the process of process.
And he came up as a process
methodologist consultant.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE]
new crystal methology.
RICH: Crystal methology, yes.
It's promising.
I can't get enough of it.
NICK BUTCHER: Anyway, here's a
good question because I know
the answer to it.
Jan [? Suza ?], I'm probably
saying that wrong, in Brazil--
watchers in Brazil--
says, "Is there any way to
use accountPicker.ne
wChooseAccountIntent
on the emulator?
Whenever I'm on the emulator,
it says nothing can handle
this."
So this actually is a subject we
just did a code lab on, on
Devoxx on Monday.
And if you check my Google+
stream, you will see that I
shared all the details, so if
you want to learn more about
using this new Google Play
Services and identity
framework, there's a
step-by-step code example that
shows you how to get
that working.
So the simple answer is no.
The Google Play searches
basically relies on APK being
installed on your device.
This is managed by
the Play Store.
The Play Store silently updates
this Google Play
services on your device.
So because the emulator doesn't
have that Play Store
or any of that infrastructure,
there's no way for it to work.
If you could somehow pull the
APK off of your device and
patch install on the emulator,
or acquire it through some
other means, that could possibly
work, but I wouldn't
know anything about
how to do that.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
I'm just trying to get hold of
the Android engineers to bring
them in, make sure that
we do get [INAUDIBLE].
All the talks are running about
20 minutes late, so they
should be finishing about--
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
RICH: What's the next one?
Does anyone from the Hangout
have a question?
I can see we've had a few
more people join us.
SPARKY RHODE: Come on everybody,
if you have
something you want to
talk about, please
just speak right up.
NICK BUTCHER: I can see
people talking.
RICH: Yeah, Sparky was just
saying that if you have a
question, just ask.
But it looks like not
so next [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: OK,
all right then.
So Andrew Kerry, again says,
"I have an action bar with
several tabs.
If I run my app in portrait
mode on a Nexus 7 running
4.1.2, and have target SDK set
to 15, the tabs are displayed
as a drop list.
However, if target SDK is
greater than 15, the tabs are
displayed as the second
row underneath.
Why the change?"
SPARKY RHODE: You'll notice
this is kind of like--
NICK BUTCHER: So I think that's
picking up on some of
the [INAUDIBLE]
sizing behavior of
the action bar.
The action bar will smartly say,
if you're trying to use
too many tabs, and it just isn't
enough room, they're
going to get too small
to be clickable.
It'll actually automatically
turn that into [INAUDIBLE]
for you.
I'm guessing there must be a
constant defined somewhere
which says, that when you have
SW6 under a DP device, over x
number of tabs, turn it
to just drop down.
And it sounds like that
changed, but I
wasn't aware of that.
I'd have to take a look
at the action bar.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, we
introduced that in Ice Cream
Sandwich with the Galaxy
Nexus phone.
I'm thinking that maybe we just,
at the time, didn't spec
that for tablet.
And the reason it comes up in
API level 15 or above is
because the Nexus 7 was our
first small tablet.
That was my guess on that one.
RICH: Fair enough.
He says that he thinks--
it doesn't matter.
NICK BUTCHER: You can
tell me later.
RICH: I can tell you later.
We'll have a deep, meaningful
discussion about it
in an hour or two.
NICK BUTCHER: I look
forward to it.
RICH: I can't get my internet
to get hold of Chet.
Can you go find Chet
[INAUDIBLE]?
What does he look like?
He looks like an Android
engineer.
NICK BUTCHER: I'l ping him.
RICH: Green, yeah green.
Green with big ears.
And the top of his head
up here somewhere.
NICK BUTCHER: He's offline.
RICH: No, just head to our
stand and see if there's
anyone that wants
to [INAUDIBLE].
It does Android.
He might have an opinion
on stuff.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
have opinions?
RICH: Chet [INAUDIBLE],
quite opinionated.
So I've been told.
NICK BUTCHER: OK,
he's French so.
RICH: [LAUGH]
NICK BUTCHER: Anyway, racial
slurring aside.
RICH: Yes.
I'm going to pay attention
to the next question.
I'm going to try and
answer it myself.
NICK BUTCHER: Any
live questions?
We seem to have more people.
RICH: Uh no, still Brian,
and Matt, and Joe.
NICK BUTCHER: This
is very weird.
I can't hear anything
back from you guys.
RICH: They aren't talking.
They are being really,
really quiet today.
I don't know.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, uh, I don't
know the answer to that one.
RICH: Dare I ask-- has anyone
managed to order a Nexus 4?
Oh Chris, did you manage
to order a Nexus 4?
CHRIS: Just a few.
RICH: Did any of them
arrive today?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
RICH: Oh, that's a shame.
CHRIS: The 10s have shipped,
but the 4s haven't yet--
I don't know.
RICH: OK, yeah I heard some
people, saw some pictures of
10s appearing on the
Google+ streams.
Hopefully we get our shipping
sorted out.
Tablets have [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, next question in the
moderator says, it's from
Shaki Amman in India, probably
saying that wrong. "I would
like to develop a plug-in for
the Google Maps app, or
perhaps a lab feature dealing
with the favorite places
people mark.
Is it possible for third
party developers"
--to do this, I guess.
"Does Google Maps expose some
APIs, or is it able to
interact with other apps?"
So if I'm interpreting
that correctly, the
answer's pretty much no.
There's no plug-in
architecture.
You can't write a lab.
Labs is a feature of
the application.
It doesn't query the device--
other people's labs.
RICH: Yeah, so the Google Maps
app on Android itself doesn't
expose that plug-in feature
or labs, or like that.
Obviously, you've got the map
view, if you want edit into
your own application, or there
is a Google Maps API on the
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So basically, it
sounds like they are trying to
work out the places people
have starred.
I don't know, intimately, the
Google maps API, whether or
not you can query that for
a user's accounts.
I don't know.
It may even be intent
rule passed.
I doubt it.
RICH: I somehow doubt it.
I doubt you get access to where
other people's favorites.
The Places API, maybe.
No, it's not likely, is it?
It's quite personal, isn't it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so I
don't think you'll be
able to do it on device.
I think your best bet is to look
into the Google Maps API
and work out whether or not you
can do an authenticated
web call to find out the user's
favorites and then go
from there.
That's your best
bet, I believe.
RICH: [LAUGH]
Alfredo's just joined us from
behind the camera--
our fantastic Italian
counterpart.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: Do you want to come
in and say hello?
Yeah, why not.
Hey!
Alfredo.
I did a code lab in Florence
with Alfredo recently.
ALFREDO: Yep, hi guys.
RICH: We're kind of down there,
up there, and the
microphone's over here.
ALFREDO: 1, 2, 3, OK.
RICH: And only I can
hear what they say.
I think they're saying
you are very nice.
ALFREDO: OK, thank you.
Hi guys.
NICK BUTCHER: Good T-shirt.
ALFREDO: Yes, it's from the fest
Sicily, the communities
that organized the fest.
RICH: Yeah, Have you had a
chance to look at the new
Android SDK yet?
I downloaded it yesterday and
the I read some documentation
on it, yes, but tonight
I want to experiment
with the new API.
RICH: Which one?
ALFREDO: Particularly
the Daydream API.
Yes, I want to play with a kind
of application that gets
photos from the quickstream of
the box, and show them on your
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH: If you write that tonight,
then we can have it
on our stand tomorrow all day,
and then we can just leave.
ALFREDO: Yeah, yeah, in
fact I want to try.
RICH: It'd be a self-maintaining
stand.
ALFREDO: Yeah, have to grab a
lot of caffeine, a lot of
coffee, a lot of things to
stay up all the night.
RICH: Have you checked out
the Daydream API yet?
ALFREDO: No, no still.
I'm very curious.
RICH: Maybe you can come back
and join us next week.
ALFREDO: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Maybe we can take
the source code of the
photo table Daydream, which
is like one [INAUDIBLE].
ALFREDO: Yes, very similar.
And provide the photo
not from the gallery
but from the stream.
RICH: Awesome.
NICK BUTCHER: Excellent.
ALFREDO: Hey, you look very
nice with this hairpiece.
RICH: Hairpiece?
[LAUGH]
NICK BUTCHER: Hairpiece?
RICH: It's very fine,
this head piece.
I don't know if anyone else has
said anything at all, or
if it's just broken.
Head piece, yes.
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: OK, cheers.
Do you want to come up?
ALFREDO: Please.
RICH: Yeah, come on, Paul.
Paul Kinlan.
NICK BUTCHER: The
man, the legend.
RICH: There he is.
Joining us here at Devoxx,
team Google London.
ALFREDO: Microphone,
screen, camera.
PAUL KINLAN: Hello.
RICH: [LAUGH]
what are doing here
at Devoxx, Paul?
What the hell are you doing
here at Devoxx?
PAUL KINLAN: How
did you get in?
RICH: This Java Conference.
They like to know about the best
bit about the web, and
where the web's going, and all
this type of stuff, so, we get
to talk about Chrome, and what
we're doing in the web, and I
will talk closer, I apologize.
Yeah, we're here to talk about
HTML5, JavaScript, all the
things that modern Java
developers use for their
client side technology.
Excellent.
Can we talk today?
PAUL KINLAN: A [INAUDIBLE]
talk, actually, at eight.
So if anyone's watching-- yes.
RICH: And if anyone knows where
that term came from,
please tell us.
PAUL KINLAN: So at 8 o' clock
we're doing 8 Chrome apps.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH: We should [INAUDIBLE]
what we did.
We never really told anyone,
but it's online, and people
can do it now.
So on Monday this week, we
have a 3-hour workshop on
integrating Google Drive into
Android applications.
So we had a wonderful, exciting
notepad application.
But it was just offline,
shockingly
offline, you could say.
If you deleted it, you'd
lose all your data.
And that's not how we roll.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
it used Roboto light
because I made it.
RICH: It used Roboto light so
that everyone in the room who
didn't have the API level, the
4.1 SDK is all [? compile ?]
project without [INAUDIBLE]
the style.
It takes about an hour.
You go through the Google
Drive setup online.
You put a few libraries
in your project.
And then you can synchronize
files with a
user's Google Drive.
PAUL KINLAN: So how does it
work, is that intent driven?
Or is it a--
NICK BUTCHER: Just using
the Drive API.
RICH: I really like it giving
a user their own data as
opposed to it coming into my
server and then not really
trusting new [INAUDIBLE]
I like the fact that it's
there on Google Drive.
They can see it.
They can edit it online.
They see it.
It syncs to all their devices.
Giving people their own data
is definitely the future.
NICK BUTCHER: And you don't
have to build your own
backend, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's nice.
That's why I like it.
RICH: Yeah, there's not
server-side switch at all.
Google Drive.
So that went through the
G+ stream yesterday.
We should repost--
is there a link somewhere
to the worksheet?
NICK BUTCHER: Just
got to my stream.
I think, I don't know.
RICH: Yeah go on plus, Nick
Butcher, and plus him.
And plus his again.
And you'll find the links.
NICK BUTCHER: Just
once is enough.
PAUL KINLAN: If you plus him
again, it's unfollow.
RICH: Well yeah, that's kind
of what I was aiming for.
OK, next muffin.
Next muffin?
Next muffin, all right.
NICK BUTCHER: So Lars
in Amsterdam.
I wonder if you're going to
DroidCon Holland next week,
we'll be there, maybe
see you there?
Maybe?
Anyway.
Lars says, "I have a series of
PDF links in my app I would
like to open inside my app.
But almost all the PDF libraries
are licensed so that
I need to open source my app.
Should I intent it to a PDF
viewer app or try to find a
library and build
it into my app?"
RICH: Good question
Lars from Holland.
Is there an answer down
there, or should I
just rattle on off?
NICK BUTCHER: Sparky says this
is a great question.
Then Andrew K proposes whether
web views can open PDF, which
they can't
RICH: If you found an online
viewer for PDFs it could.
CHRIS: Google Docs
does, or Drive.
NICK BUTCHER: OK,
so generally--
RICH: Yeah, yeah, Chris just
said Drive can, which it can.
So potentially, you could upload
it to Drive and open it
using our Drive API that
we gave a talk on.
And that is at least a
free way of doing it.
PDF is a platform
that's licensed.
Generally, you do have to
license a product for it if
you want to include it inside
your application.
PAUL KINLAN: Use PDF JS if
it's inside of web view.
RICH: Apparently you can
use PDF JS if it's
inside of web view.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL KINLAN: It is an
open source one.
But I think it might be
readily licensed and
[INAUDIBLE].
It doesn't mean your
RICH: Potentially, you could
use PDF to JS, or Google
Drive, or license a solution.
NICK BUTCHER: So my answer would
be, it also comes down
to the kind of data.
Like if it's something that only
makes sense within the
context of your app, so I've
seen apps that are basically
like textbook apps, which, they
want to keep you within
the application and just use
PDF as the rendering
technology.
Then that makes sense to
try and find a library.
Whereas if it's something
where the content stands
alone, then
I think then that lends
itself more to--
the Androidy way would
probably be
to fire off an intent.
And why rebuild, why reinvent
the wheel when they're apps
our there like [INAUDIBLE] is my
favorite PDF reader, which
offers tons of great
functionality, annotations and
all that good stuff.
Why rebuild all that when you
can just pass it off?
So yeah, it depends
on the content.
RICH: So Chris Bangs actually
chips in with "are these guys
on something?" Thanks
for that, Chris.
CHRIS: [LAUGH]
RICH: Of course we are.
Lack of sleep, actually.
Writing a three hour
Drive presentation.
NICK BUTCHER: Or a [? Leffe ?]
comedown, maybe.
RICH: A [? Leffe ?]
comedown or not.
Sorry about that.
PAUL KINLAN: You go to
[? inn ?] last night?
RICH: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Nice.
RICH: And then, Joe says, "Yeah,
you could launch your
intents from Google Drive to
open the file." Excellent
suggestion.
And Sparky has put the
link to our code lab.
Can you put that on comment
thread as well, Sparky?
On the plus Android
developers.
ALFREDO: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: Yeah, but only people
inside the Hangout
can see this one.
Everybody to get access to it.
But don't put it on YouTube.
NICK BUTCHER: Shall I
go to the next, the
last Moderator one?
I'm going to skip one of them
because it links out to Stack
Overflow, which I can't get to
because my internet's not.
Burr Richard Thomson asks, "If
I have an app that displays a
list of places and then places
on a map, you could switch
between them with a dropdown
on the action bar.
If the app offers other
features, which is the best
way to navigate to
other functions?
[INAUDIBLE] ."
So my answer would be, so that
sounds more like filtering the
same kind of data.
So yeah, if you have the same
lists and you have two
representations, like a map
representation and a list
representation, you could
use a drop down.
You could use overlay tabs.
Might work quite nicely
in that situation.
But then, if you had other
navigation options, then you'd
probably would want to go up a
[? speed ?] to get to those.
You probably wouldn't want to
have one navigation type
affordance as well as a global
navigation affordance That
sounds like it's getting
a little bit too much.
You could do that with
a global drop downs,
[? spin it, ?]
and then tabs underneath
to do the change
between map and list.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH: I've seen that before.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
You could use a fly-in.
RICH: A fly-in.
NICK BUTCHER: I think fly-in
works well when you have a
list of stuff.
Not so well when it's
a couple of things.
It depends, again.
Feel free to post some
sketches of what
you're trying to build.
And mention that so we can chime
in with a few bits of
feedback as well.
It's hard to talk about
it in the abstract.
RICH: Absolutely.
RICH: Sparky, in the meantime,
are you following the plus
Android developer's comments,
in case there are any?
Because we can't see
them from this end.
On the G+ post.
We should get some questions
in there.
More people asking to be
added to the Hangout.
I think he's looking.
Everyone's very, very quiet.
NICK BUTCHER: One question I
can show you, which I don't
know answer to, "Does the new
Bluetooth stack in 4.2 support
BTE, Bluetooth for
Low Energy?"
RICH: Oh my god, we can have
a conversation about this.
My Bluetooth knowledge
is not good enough.
I know that we have
Bluetooth 4.0.
The Nexus 4 has it.
I know there is a new
Bluetooth stack.
I don't know how all the
different profiles and into
API levels--
does Bluetooth 4 mean that has
things like low energy?
I don't know what Bluetooth
4 encompasses.
Whether it means it has
a health profile--
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not an Android guy.
No I mean, not in Android,
but just,
generally, in the real world.
Does anyone in the Hangout
have any knowledge on
Bluetooth, or has worked with
Bluetooth in any considerable
way before?
RICH: So I have something to
confess about Bluetooth.
Because I didn't realize I could
create a personal area
network with it.
And I used it.
[? useful ?].
And I just worked from Android
straight away.
ALFREDO: Wow it's magic.
RICH: Yeah, I just [INAUDIBLE]
all my stuff to the
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Magic.
ALFREDO: Blue magic,
not black.
RICH: Nobody in the Hangout?
AUDIENCE: So we've got one
question in the Google+ thread
if you wanted to tackle
that one.
RICH: I was still on the
Bluetooth one, if anybody had
any insights.
No, I even looked this up.
Sorry, Joe?
AUDIENCE: Wikipedia says
yeah, it does have
that in version four.
But on Wikipedia, version four
it says it has Bluetooth house
feed and Bluetooth Low Energy.
Wikipedia page says Bluetooth
four has low energy?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICH: OK.
Yeah, and again, I don't know if
we have APIs for that sort
of thing, or if it's just
taken care of by
the Bluetooth stack.
I'd imagine it's taken care of
by the Bluetooth stack from
with you can inquire if it's
in low-energy mode.
[INAUDIBLE] a device that's
going to be connected the
whole time, like a heart
rate monitor or
something, or a pulse--
I don't know.
SPARKY RHODE: I didn't think
we're at that level of
Bluetooth yet.
Sorry?
I don't think we're at that
level of the Bluetooth API
yet, though.
RICH: No, no, I don't
think we are either.
But, because I've had quite a
few questions about it now,
I'll try and look it
up during the week.
And maybe we can talk
about it next week.
Maybe we need to do an Android
developer's Bluetooth special.
[LAUGH].
One person might join.
And we'll be like, hey, this
all about Bluetooth.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
SPARKY RHODE: Also Paul
[? Hanson. ?]
RICH: Bluetooth's named
after a Viking?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
He managed to bring lots of
people to the table and they
all talked together.
And that's what Bluetooth
is, making everyone
talk to each other.
That's an epic piece
of knowledge, Nick.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, I used to
live near the capital of
Viking England.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH: Excellent.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGH]
RICH: Matt has a question
from the Android
developer's G+ thread.
AUDIENCE: Of course, so in-app
purchasing and Google Checkout
"Why can we not have a callback
functionality like a
normal Google Checkout
transaction?
It should be important that we
know the status of payment,
especially for systems created
by developers that require
licensing based on a complete
and successful payment."
RICH: Yeah.
It's an in-app billing
question.
Why can't we have a callback
for the payroll status.
NICK BUTCHER: Good feedback.
RICH: Yeah, good feedback.
We're taking on board a lot of
in-app payments feedback at
the moment.
Like the Play team took on board
a lot of feedback for
their developer console and
produced a new one, we're
taking on board feedback for
in-app billing, and we'll see
where that leads us.
Personally, I would like an
updated API of some sort.
NICK BUTCHER: I'd like
to get prices.
RICH: Being able
There's a lot of feedback
we get from conferences.
Every time we stand up in front
of an audience, they
want to know how to get prices
and, similarly, the status of
transactions.
Things like this are
very important.
So yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm going
to head off.
RICH: Thanks very much
for joining us.
PAUL KINLAN: No, thank you
for inviting me in.
And if I've ruined
it, I'm sorry.
RICH: If you want to pull
any funnier faces--
NICK BUTCHER: It was delight.
PAUL KINLAN: I wasn't
pulling funny faces.
NICK BUTCHER: That's
just his face.
This is my normal face.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, anyway,
I'm going to see
the Dart talk, so--
RICH: All right.
PAUL KINLAN: Catch
you guy later.
RICH: Seth's talking?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL KINLAN: Seth Ladd
talking about Dart.
We're doing the keynote
tomorrow.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh yeah, we're
going on about Devoxx, but
they are all going to be
available on all parlays.com.
As well, so if you hear us
talking about it, you should
check out the schedule.
There's some really,
really cool talks.
I'm really looking forward to
on from Chen Roman tomorrow
again, for better, for worse.
Get some really technical
information about the Android
rendering system.
There was a really, really
good three-hour talk from
[INAUDIBLE]
yesterday which was packed full
of tips, and tricks, and
how to get to the bottom
of performance issues.
And I learned a lot, so we'll
try and disseminate that.
RICH: Yeah, we'll have to show
those links for the parlays
when we're online, on the G+,
if people can see them.
Also, we were just up in
Chet Roman's What's
New in Android talk.
And they said there were now 560
million activated devices.
I'm not sure I'd heard
that number before.
I was still running
500 million.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
should we go to another
question?
RICH: Yeah, let's do it.
Next muffin.
NICK BUTCHER: Shall I go?
A question for Chris
in the moderator--
someone says, "what?
Have you got two new Nexus 4s?
Can I have
one?" CHRIS: No.
RICH: [LAUGH]
RICH: Sorry.
That was mean, evil and--
We did something similar in
Chet's talk when they said has
anyone got the 4.2 update yet?
NICK BUTCHER: I didn't hear.
I saw Chris pop up, so I'm
guessing you answered.
But I believe you sent or
canceled the orders, right?
They're not up for grabs.
CHRIS: Only Rich can
hear me, so.
RICH: Yeah, I can hear
you fine, Chris.
CHRIS: Yes, I ordered five
and canceled three.
RICH: Canceled three.
CHRIS: I've got two .
RICH: Two 16s?
CHRIS: Two 16s.
RICH: Good for you.
Yeah, we had a few people who
managed to order multiple.
They haven't had any trouble
uploading them.
[INAUDIBLE]
So hopefully, [INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: I read that those
Nexus 4s sold out in
Germany in 15 minutes.
RICH: Yeah, there were people
here at Devoxx who were
[INAUDIBLE]
to Germany trying to
find the device.
I think that the whole thing
was quite painful.
NICK BUTCHER: Any
live questions?
RICH: Any live questions?
Or oh, Matt's just typed
something in.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPARKY RHODE: Hey.
RICH: I really, really don't
know anymore about the
low-energy stuff.
We will, we'll try and bring
some more information to you
on the Bluetooth stack
in the coming weeks.
We might not be able to
get it next week.
Maybe we can even get a
Bluetooth engineer from the
Android team online.
NICK BUTCHER: Just
read the source.
RICH: Or just read the source.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
The API.
RICH: Come on then,
next question.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, one more?
So Alley in Chicago says, "Is
content provider testing
possible with multiple
authorities?" He needs to test
a batch operation, "but I cannot
do that with current
test case classes, as they
can only be mapped to one
authority." Does anyone know?
Because I don't.
RICH: Alfredo's searching
his memory banks.
ALFREDO: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Sorry man.
RICH: Someone who's got a PC
might be able to have a quick
look at that, but I don't have
anything off the top of my
head to test--
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
Sorry, [INAUDIBLE].
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: OK, another one
is coming in from Rob M in
London, saying he has a path,
which is SVG vector, which
he's drawing to canvas
using draw path.
"As of Jell Bean, there seems to
be a new optimization that
stops it drawing if any of the
path is below 0, 0, ie, there
are negative path points.
Is this a new optimization?
Is there a way around?"
RICH: Now that's what we need
Chet and Roman for.
Come on.
NICK BUTCHER: Roman because
he probably wrote that.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
Chet, or Roman, or both.
They usually come as a pair.
ALFREDO: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: Yeah, have a look
upstairs, around the place.
Maybe you can--
ALFREDO: Yes, I will
be back with him.
RICH: If you find him, don't
let him get away because he
could answer this question.
NICK BUTCHER: So we don't
know the answer,
Roman definitely will.
We will try and track him down,
and if we don't get him
before the end of the show, we
will reply in the Moderator.
But I'm guessing yes.
I believe, actually, we only
added support for draw path to
be done by the hardware
rendering
pipeline as of 4.1 right.
So that sounds like it could
be exactly this.
So if it was previously being
done by the software pipeline,
and then we switch to the new
hardware rendering pipeline,
you might perhaps switch this
kind of change in behavior.
RICH: You could always find out
by testing with hardware.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, if you're
talking like a [? target ?]
SDK of 16 or more, you'll
automatically opt into the
hardware pipeline.
You could get in a view and
say set layer type to
software, which will turn off
the hardware accelerator to
the pipline, and see if you
get the old behavior.
And then you can be sure that
it is a hardware/software
rendering issue.
RICH: I'd imagine it is.
It sounds a lot like one.
Cool.
OK.
Was that Matt just jumping
out and jumping in again?
MATT: Yep.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Last question I
could see in the Moderator
here comes from Gregory
[? Mince ?] saying, he has
several pressure ports reporting
a SQL [? Light ?]
exception which says can't
upgrade, read any database in
version 0.2.3.
And it only occurs on some
devices, particularly one
U8860 something device.
Any ideas why this may occur?
AUDIENCE: That sounds
like [INAUDIBLE].
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
a little bit more
context on that.
NICK BUTCHER: I know.
RICH: Is he trying
to update his--
what luck.
Is it in his own [? name? ?]
AUDIENCE: Do you think that's
a Huawei device?
Sounds like it.
RICH: It was a what,
sorry joe?
AUDIENCE: A Huawei?
I don't know how to
say it properly--
the Chinese one?
RICH: The [? five ?]
[? dye ?] class?
AUDIENCE: A Huawei device?
RICH: Oh, a Huawei device.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Huawei.
RICH: Huawei, yeah, yeah, I
think it probably is as well.
NICK BUTCHER: So if it's a
device-specific issue, like,
if it's working fine on a bunch
of other devices, then
I'd say, for now I would
blacklist the device in the
supported device section
of Play Store console.
And then I would try and either
get hold of a device or
perhaps use a service like
testdroid.com to try
and debug the issue.
I'm not sure we're going to be
able to do much offhand here
about more logs.
RICH: Yeah, it's
a strange one.
Trying to upgrade read only
database problem?
NICK BUTCHER: It's a
speculation, I think.
Sparky said something about it
might be running out of space.
No Andrew [? Kelley ?]
says this.
RICH: Yeah, if you can get any
more details of the code that
you're running through the
database upgrade, any stack
traces that you're seeing, put
them into the Moderator and
we're going to have
a look at that.
Or come back next week with an
updated question with a little
bit more context so we can look
into it during the week.
Yeah, with all bugs, the key is
being able to replicate, I
guess, so perhaps getting hold
of the device somehow, like
virtually or physically.
RICH: But you can always have
a look in your Google Play
developer console.
And in there, have a look at
crash reports, and [INAUDIBLE]
stack track because I'm guessing
that's where you're
seeing it anyway.
But if you can get a stack trace
out of there and send it
to us, ready for next week's
office hours, hopefully we can
come up with an answer
for you.
NICK BUTCHER: He's linked to
some stuff in the question.
So maybe he's done that--
RICH: Oh, sorry.
Hopefully it's at Stack
Overflow or something.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH: OK
NICK BUTCHER: Are there any
comments in the plus thread?
RICH: Here's a good
hint for you guys.
So if you get your Android 4.2
device and you want to plug it
in to the USB to get your USB
debugging connected up to your
Android SDK, you're going to
hit the Settings screen.
You can either drag down
once from the top or
twice from the top.
And hit Settings.
Get through to Settings, and
you'll scroll down to the
bottom, and you won't find
developer options anymore.
Oh my god!
Da-da-da-da-da.
Hopefully it's been going
around on G+.
But because we have 560 million
users, and only a
fraction of them are actual
Android developers, we've
hidden the developer
options now.
So you now go right down to the
bottom of Settings to the
advanced screen, and start
tapping on the build line.
You tap it, and then it says
five, four, three, two, one.
You keep tapping, and then it
says, congratulations, you are
now the developer.
And then developer options
will reappear.
If you run multi-user system on
a new Nexus 10 tablet, go
to be the primary
user to do that.
Multi-user system, the first
person who logs in is the
primary user, and they have
control over that.
They can delete through accounts
and [? once ?] we can
get access to the debugging
options.
I just thought I'd throw that
in there, because we've
already had that question once,
and we're bound to get
it get a couple more times.
NICK BUTCHER: So I think
we exhausted
the Moderator thread.
In the G+ announcement posts,
Michael [? Back ?] asks what
our favorite APIs in
Android 4.2 are.
I think we've given our
favorites, so I went for
presentation API,
and [INAUDIBLE],
and stuff like that.
And Rich went for Daydreams,
did you say?
RICH: Oh, I don't know.
I think locked-screen
widgets for me.
NICK BUTCHER: You're
Mr. Widget.
RICH: I am Mr. Widget.
NICK BUTCHER: Search for Widget,
and you find his app.
First result, no second
result now.
Beautiful Widgets
edged you out.
RICH: Beautiful Widgets, damn
your Beautiful Widgets.
They're just so pretty.
NICK BUTCHER: And they work
on a locked screen.
And they have a Daydream.
RICH: OK, OK, easy, easy.
Damn you.
Yeah, so locked-screen widgets,
the same API as
normal widgets.
NICK BUTCHER: One.
One feature.
Favorite feature.
RICH: I was just going to tell
them what locked-screen
[INAUDIBLE].
But yeah, locked-screen widgets,
favorite feature.
Because I want [INAUDIBLE] and
the music [? to both ?] have
locked-screen widgets, so when
I'm running I can just see
both, and I don't need
to unlock my phone.
I just want to hit the power
button-- oh yeah, I've done 12
kilometers, and I'm listening
to [MICHAEL JACKSON SOUND].
NICK BUTCHER: But I think
it's a good question.
I want to open it up to you
guys who are live in the
Hangout here.
If you've had a chance to look
at the 4.2 APIs, what's the
things that you're most excited
about and can't wait
to implement in your apps.
And Rich is going to have to
tell me what they say.
RICH: Go ahead, one by one.
Starting with Chris.
CHRIS: I think the
Presentation API.
I haven't had a play with it
yet, but I think the power of
it and what you can do with
it is pretty massive.
RICH: Yeah, if you want to see
an example of that, we've got
a device [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Or there's the
example in the API demos.
RICH: And there's an
example there.
AUDIENCE: I like the the
Presentation as well because
it would be really useful being
able to just seamlessly
show some content.
It would be really good.
But as well, I saw Dreams in the
support package before it
launched, and I thought,
what on Earth is that?
RICH: So he did spot Dreams
in the support
package for his launch.
What the hell is that?
Well, that's Presentation,
Presentation, did you say
Presentation?
Three to Presentation.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I think I'm going
to go for Daydreams.
That one is quite an
interesting one.
RICH: We've got one for
Daydreams, three for
presentation, one for
Loxby widgets.
Richard Thompson, maybe you
can type in the sidebar
[INAUDIBLE]
whilst Sparky tells us
what his favorite new
API in the SDK is.
SPARKY RHODE: I don't know if it
counts as an API very much,
but honestly, I think my
favorite new feature is
improved bi-directional tech
support because I'm really
excited about opening up Android
to that next couple of
billion users.
RICH: Improved bi-directional
tech support.
To open up Android to the extra
couple of billion users.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH: That's looking
at the big picture.
NICK BUTCHER: Pro-tip with
that is don't use the new
constants as well.
We used to use gravity left,
gravity right in your layouts.
So you'd see like gravity to
text, one side or the other.
You now want to be looking at
using gravity star and gravity
n so that that will do the right
thing in right to left
languages, rather than
just left to right.
And it's completely backward
compatible because it's a bit
like [INAUDIBLE].
So it will still work on
older devices as well.
So take a look at the constants
when you set the
gravity on text.
But yeah, good point.
RICH: And I think we've just
been joined by Al Sutton.
AL SUTTON: Hey guys.
RICH: There it is, it's
definitely Al, stuck in a tiny
thumbnail in the very,
very distance.
NICK BUTCHER: Ooh-yeah.
RICH: Ooh-yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] making a joke.
NICK BUTCHER: See what I did?
RICH: So jumping straight in
there, Al, what's your
favorite new API
in the new SDK?
I bet you've checked
it out already.
AL SUTTON: Oh yeah, There's
one method that
I absolutely love.
And that's User Manager
dot Is A Goat.
RICH: User Manager
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
that you'd spotted that User
Manager dot Is A Goat exists.
NICK BUTCHER: Always
was though.
RICH: And what was the
description of the method?
AL SUTTON: It tells you whether
the user is a goat
capable of transplantation.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
It tells you whether the user is
capable of transportation.
NICK BUTCHER: So you can now
check if the user is a monkey,
and if the user is a goat.
But user is a monkey
is actually useful.
AL SUTTON: [LAUGH]
RICH: It is actually, true.
AUDIENCE: I saw something
on Google+ about
that relating to Chrome.
Because Chrome has some menu--
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It's on Chrome as
well about goats being
teleported.
RICH: Something about how fast
[INAUDIBLE] teleporting.
AL SUTTON: Yeah,
it's on Chrome.
On Chrome, if you go into
the debug options.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AL SUTTON: How many goats
have been transported.
RICH: How many goats have
been transported is a
debug option in Chrome?
How many goats have been
transported is a
debug option in Chrome?
AL SUTTON: One of the Collins.
RICH: Paul's nodding.
Paul Kinlan.
[INAUDIBLE]
He's never tried it himself.
NICK BUTCHER: But no one
says [INAUDIBLE].
RICH: We need to go deeper.
AL SUTTON: [LAUGH]
RICH: Chris was asking about
that on G+ earlier today.
So that was three for
presentation.
Three for people who care about
just watching stuff on
their own big TV.
One for the rest of the world.
[INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: OK, I'm going to
give a few pro-tips as well,
new stuff in developer
settings.
So when you've done your tap,
tap to get your developer
options back, there's a few new
interesting settings you
want to take a look at.
First one, I'm going to say is
the yeah, if you want to
develop these presentations
but you don't have a TV or
Miracast display, there's a new
option to emulate a second
display so that you can develop
for it and your device
will see a second display.
Second one I'm going to talk
about is what was it I was
going to say?
RICH: Developer options.
NICK BUTCHER: Over draw.
Over draw.
So there's a new option in
there so you can tell the
hardware rendering pipeline to
overlay how much over drawing
you're doing.
So I think that's one of
biggest problems in
applications' performance.
So if you're try to just
basically do too much.
So we're all lazy, just
don't do any work.
You don't have to, basically.
This is a cool tool in developer
options which will
overlay in blue, if you're
drawing twice, or green, if
you're drawing three times.
Or like red, if you're drawing
the pixels five times, which
is extremely wasteful.
[INAUDIBLE]
So that's really, really cool
way to know if you're doing
too much work.
And then you can use the tracer
for Open GLES tool,
which is part of the SDK to
actually step through your
rendering operations and work
out, oh, I'm drawing an opaque
background.
And I'm drawing a completely
opaque layer on top of that.
So that's completely wasted
drawing pixels.
[INAUDIBLE]
so that's a super tool.
RICH: Absolutely, yeah.
Roman ran through some examples
yesterday where he'd
been doing this, reducing the
number of layers of drawing
and the [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yes, if you want
to get buttery smooth
scrolling lists, then
don't be drawing
every pixel five times.
RICH: We just spotted a Jake
Wharton walking by as well.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: Who's now got no choice
but to come on and say hello.
NICK BUTCHER: So we're doing
our regular Office Hours
Hangout, and unfortunately
there's no sound.
Only Rich can hear--
RICH: I can hear all the guys
and they say [INAUDIBLE]
as well.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
Do you want to say hello, and
what you do, and what you're
doing here at Devoxx?
JAKE WHARTON: Sure.
So I'm--
My name is Jake Wharton, I work
at Square, and I do a ton
of open source stuff.
Speaking about all the open
source projects that I've done
and Square puts out and
hopefully getting some
excitement for all these
projects and so that everyone
can make better apps.
NICK BUTCHER: So if you don't
know, Jake writes a Action Bar
[INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH: So I'm asking now, do
you have statistics on the
number of applications that
are using your libraries?
JAKE WHARTON: Uh, no.
But [? apres ?]
website, they do lists, and
it's pretty high up.
I think it was in the top 10.
NICK BUTCHER: The support
library--
JAKE WHARTON: The support
library's way at the top.
It's like 20%.
I mean it's only something
like 1% of installs.
RICH: 1% of installs?
JAKE WHARTON: Yeah, and that's
only whatever they track.
NICK BUTCHER: But that's all
the best apps because they
care about having an
action bar across--
JAKE WHARTON: Right.
But it's also only free apps.
Because I don't think they can
get data from paid apps.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, really.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AL SUTTON: Can you give him a
pat on the back in a combined
thanks from everyone here?
Because [INAUDIBLE]
library.
RICH: Al says, can we give you
a combined thanks from
everyone here and the entire
Android developer community.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, bravo sir.
RICH: Thanks very much, Jake.
JAKE WHARTON: You're welcome.
RICH: Cool.
How are we doing for time?
My clock is minuscule
and a long way away.
NICK BUTCHER: Five minutes to.
RICH: OK, in the last five
minutes are there any more
questions coming in on the
comments thread or live from
the Hangout?
AL SUTTON: I can probably answer
the one about the SQL
database one earlier about
getting the error
about the read only?
RICH: Cheers Jake,
thanks very much
JAKE WHARTON: OK, bye.
RICH: Go on then.
Go on, give a quick answer
if [INAUDIBLE].
AL SUTTON: I've come across the
read-only problem before.
It was on early versions
of Android 2.
And the best way to get around
it was to do a get writeable
on create and then close the
database straight afterwards.
It's pretty hacky, but it seemed
to solve the issue in
almost every case.
RICH: Excellent.
I think that solves the issue,
probably, as well.
[INAUDIBLE]
Talk about this later.
All right, I think we're
finished with the Moderator.
Matt, were there any
more questions on
the comments thread?
MATT: Um, no, we've kind of
had a couple requests for
whether there's going to be an
official doc for the Nexus 4
and other devices.
Daydream will work.
RICH: An officialy doc
for the Nexus 4.
The Nexus 4 [INAUDIBLE] while
it's charging, and Daydreams
will work when it's docked
into that, yes.
NICK BUTCHER: When you set up
Daydreams, you have the choice
to tell it when to dream.
So the choices are--
when docked, when
on power, or both.
So you can choose
one of those.
RICH: I'm looking forward to
getting hold of the Nexus 4's
official wireless charger.
I haven't seen one myself yet,
but I've seen a video from it.
It is a standard, the wireless
charging standard we're using.
So we use a power plate of
some sort in the office.
I think it's Energizer,
the one we've got?
So you can get these things off
Amazon relatively cheap,
for kind of $20.
NICK BUTCHER: I think the Nokia
ones work as well, the
little pillow.
RICH: Yeah. we're a embracing
the standards with the
wireless charger.
But it's really nice just to
be able to drop it down on
your bedside table.
NICK BUTCHER: I can't
for Ikea to build it
into my bedside table.
RICH: Oh, I want furniture.
[INAUDIBLE]
AL SUTTON: Do we know if, by
default, Android daydreams of
electric sheep?
RICH: Do we know if, by default,
if Android daydreams
of electric sheep?
Question?
NICK BUTCHER: That sounds
like a [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGH].
RICH: I think Asimov's
out of copyright.
[INAUDIBLE]
still the handy games
app recently.
Maybe?
It would be Epic and
Handy games to
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH: Daydream.
And you could just sit
and [? sheep ?].
Please do that.
NICK BUTCHER: Do it.
RICH: That would be epic.
RICH: We'll give you a shout
out in the next office
hours if you do.
OK.
I think we're out of time.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH: And all that's left to say
is thank you for joining
us here from Devoxx.
NICK BUTCHER: I hope you can
hear us and make it all out.
RICH: Yeah.
We'll be posting the links to
the Parlay site for the
Android talks that were given
here at Devoxx with a little
bit of a brief rundown
on them.
The general what's new at
Android talk, for better or
for worse, and of course
[INAUDIBLE]
on integrating Drive.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, and Jake's
talk on using all the awesome
Square open source tooling to
bootstrap your development.
Obviously it's going to
be on Parlays as well.
Look out of that.
I'm sure it will be excellent.
RICH: OK
NICK BUTCHER: And yeah, you can
go to my profile, and I've
shared a link to the code out
that we gave on using Drive to
sync data between your apps, and
the web, and everywhere,
so that everything
stays in sync.
RICH: Again, thank you very much
for the people who joined
us live in the Hangout.
It helps us out massively today
when we couldn't hear,
read, or speak with
any of you.
NICK BUTCHER: Ah, conferences.
RICH: Yes, cheers all of you.
Thank you very much.
And we'll see you next week.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye.
AUDIENCE: Bye guys.
CHRIS: See you.
AL SUTTON: Bye everyone.